Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wunderst du dich, wo ich bin? Ja, ja, ich bin im Büro.
Weißt du, wo ich bin? Im neuen Büro. Das heißt wahrscheinlich schon ab Februar werden wir hier aus dem Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel aus Podcast machen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ich bin schon mal eingezogen für dich. Ich guck schon mal das aus.
Wo Teams vernetzt sind und Ideen wachsen, liefert Internet at Work von Vodafone Highspeed für ihr Business.
Together we can.
Genau, du hast mir heute Morgen geschrieben.
Ja, das ist nicht der Grund, dass du ein neues Büro bezogen hast, weshalb wir uns jetzt hier unterhalten, sondern ich habe dir heute morgen spontan geschrieben und sagte, sollen wir nicht vielleicht doch mal zwischendurch kurz etwas aufnehmen, um etwas klarzustellen? Und zwar gibt es ja, wie ich finde zu Recht, sehr heftige Diskussionen über Aussagen, die getroffen wurden ziemlich zu Beginn des, der vergangenen Folge, also wo wir vor dem Salon stehen und ich einleite, wir müssen mal über Epstein reden. Und ich will nur jetzt damit alle im Bilde sind, sagen, was da gefallen ist und worüber jetzt sehr heftig diskutiert wird. Also du hast das Wort ergriffen und sagt es dann. Und jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, was es für ein Backlash geben wird. Also es ging darum, wie das jetzt politisch wirkt, diese Epstein-Files und all das. Was es für ein Backlash geben wird, Zitat, weil irgendwo echte Menschen irgendwie Babys gefuttert haben und weil sie dachten, wenn sie unter Stress diese töten, entsteht da irgendein Hormon und so weiter. Daraufhin habe ich und das wurde auch kritisiert, ich würde auch sagen zu Recht kritisiert, nicht vehement genug widersprochen, sondern sagte nur, du gehst aber jetzt noch weiter als das, was gerade publiziert wurde, worauf du dann geantwortet hast, nein, das wurde alles publiziert. Also das mit dem Stresszustand und dass man da im richtigen Moment Menschen töten muss, um an dieses Hormon dranzukommen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hat das Gespräch dann einen anderen Lauf hier noch genommen. Aber um diese Stelle geht es und ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht widersprochen weiter, weil du das auch mit so einer Überzeugungskraft dann gesagt hast, das ist alles publiziert. Ich dachte, okay, es ist so viel gerade publiziert. Ich bin ja auch nur so halb im Nachrichtenfluss und kann nicht alles aufnehmen. Ich werde mal auch zu Hause noch mal gucken. Dann habe ich natürlich sehr viel gegoogelt und sehr wenig gefunden. Insofern jetzt die Frage, wie war es gemeint?
Also es war nicht ganz so gemeint, wie es da steht. Ich will mich auch nicht rausreden. Also ich bin schon wahnsinnig interessiert an diesen Appsteensachen, weil wer ja unseren Podcast verfolgt, weiß ja, dass ich mich für eine Sache besonders interessiere. Das ist die Demografie. Und dann für diese Geschichte, das ist unsere Einleitung, wie viel findet statt abseits von unserer bewussten Beteiligung, insbesondere im politischen Gespräch? Also Leute sind wütend, weil sie vor fünf Jahren gehört haben, sie müssten jetzt gendern. Niemand hat das Gendern je eingeführt, aber trotzdem führte es zu gewissen Sachen. Und jetzt ist es so, die New York Times macht ja jetzt auch Podcasts, in dem sie schon behaupten, das gesamte Material gesichtet zu haben. Aber der Podcast ist trotzdem nur 20 Minuten lang, was für mich bedeutet, ich habe ja keine Eile, ich warte einfach ab, wer das Sachbuch wettern jetzt gewinnt, und dann sehen wir einfach in zwei Jahren, was da drin steht. Ich habe aber sehr wohl vernommen, dass bei uns im Smalltalk Forum und so weiter die Emotionen so ein bisschen hochkochten und gleich wieder diese Idee aufkam, sobald man unterstellt, dass Superreicher als distinktive Klasse sich absondern und geheime Sachen planen, ist man schon im Antisemitismus. So, weil das ist nur eine Schiffre für, eigentlich sind es die Juden oder was auch immer. Davon will ich mich ja komplett freimachen. Wir werden am Monatsende auf die Sachen kommen, die wir interessant finden, weil wir Clips dazu haben, also in irgendeiner Art und Weise ist dann publiziert, zu diesen Sachen, 20 Frauen gleichzeitig schwanger halten durch Jeffrey Epstein und dann diese Babys auch nutzen.
Ja, Moment, aber ob die genutzt wurden, das ist ja gerade das, was nicht zu finden ist. Also es geht ja darum, dass Jeffrey Epstein, und da gab es diverse Artikel, ob in Bild-Zeitung oder hier Berliner Zeitung. Da geht es zum Beispiel um diese Zorro-Range in New Mexico. Eine Babyfarm für die Ewigkeit wurde das auch überschrieben, also eine Farm, die Epstein 1993 gekauft hat. Und dann steht hier auch klar in der Berliner Zeitung sein Ziel, bis zu 20 Frauen gleichzeitig zu schwängern, um die menschliche Rasse mit seiner DNA zu besiedeln. Das war in Anführungszeichen gesetzt, also aus den Akten wohl zitiert. Ergänzt wurde dieser Plan durch transhumanistische Ideen. So äußerte Epstein den Wunsch, seinen Kopf und sein männliches Glied nach seinem Tod einfrieren zu lassen, in der Hoffnung auf eine technologische Wiedergeburt. Dass Epstein ungestört operieren konnte, verdankte er seinen Verbindungen zur lokalen Elite. Und dann wird so ein bisschen da erklärt, wie das überhaupt funktioniert hat und was der Governor da für eine Rolle gespielt hat. Jedenfalls ist ja nicht irgendwo in zumindest der seriösen Presse zu lesen, auch nicht in den New York Times, dass wir es jetzt mit entweder Kannibalismus zu tun haben oder dass wir sagen können, diese Kinder wurden irgendwie zur Organspende oder sonst was genutzt. Was man noch hat als weiteres Gerücht, nur um das anzuführen, das ist jetzt ein Artikel aus der Bild-Zeitung. Siehst, sie haben mich überall rumgetrieben. Da geht es um ein Mädchen, minderjährig war sie da, die einmal wohl vergewaltigt worden sein soll von einem Mitarbeiter von Epstein. Der Fall ist noch nicht geklärt. Zudem gibt es Tagebuchaufzeichnungen von ihr, in der diese junge Frau schreibt, dass sie sich wie ein menschlicher Brutkasten vorkommt, dass sie ein Kind ausgetragen hat, mutmaßlich von Jeffrey Epstein, mit der Begründung auch, sie habe gute Gene, sie könne gut Klavier spielen und so weiter. Und da ist jetzt die Frage. Im Jahr 2019 berichtete die New York Times, dass Epsteins Wissenschaftler bereits Anfang der 2000er mehrfach mitgeteilt habe, er wolle die Menschheit verbessern, indem er mit seinem Sperrmann dutzende Frauen auf seiner Ranch in New Mexico schwängere. Falls die Behauptungen, also dieses Opfers, mutmaßlichen Opfers, stimmen, ist auch unklar, steht hier, was mit dem Neugeborenen passiert ist. Also das heißt, es gibt natürlich Unklarheiten. Und ich will an dieser Stelle auch sagen, ich kann mir inzwischen alles Schreckliche vorstellen, was vorgefallen ist da noch. Nur würde ich ja schon sagen, es ist ja gerade sehr viel an Fakten da, was grauenhaft genug ist. Und wir brauchen ja nicht noch was hinzufügen, was noch nicht da ist oder auch vielleicht nie da sein wird.
Ja, genau. Und das ist, finde ich, diese interessante Zweigleisigkeit. Also das wir zum einen die jungen Frauen und dann aber auch so ein Harem an Akademikern haben, also Klammer auf Joscha Bach und so, die einfach mit Geld zugemöbelt werden, damit die so einen Semi-Kontakt zu irgendwelchen Unis halten, falls mal irgendeine Forschung abfällt. Und es gibt ja einige Fotos, wie Epstein da mit Leuten im Kreis sitzt, an der Tafel ist irgendwas gemalt, und dann macht man sich so Gedanken über das eine oder andere. Und was auf jeden Fall da drin steckt, und was mich auch wahnsinnig dann interessiert, aber das, wie gesagt, habe ich keine Eile, da warte ich auf die Sachbücher, die dann kommen, ist diese handfeste Eugenik-Idee, die da drin steckt. Dass man über die Gene in so ein demografisches Schicksal eines Landes eingreifen kann. Wahrscheinlich ist das ja so, also vielleicht auch so einen patriotischen Einschlag, wie man jetzt Amerika wieder zum exzeptionellen Land macht, wie auch immer. Wenn so eine Demografie aufkommt in solchen Kreisen, ist meine Vermutung, ist so eine biologische Dimension davon immer nicht weit. Also, dass wirklich jemand auf eine Idee kommt, ja, was wäre jetzt, wenn man dieses Blut als Saftgottes, was auch immer, also das geht ja da tausende Jahre zurück. Da ist ja sozusagen auch diese Art von Forschung, in Anführungszeichen, bevor es Wissenschaft gab, zumindest gut historisch dargelegt. Es würde mich gerade zu wundern, wenn es diese biologische Dimension diesmal nicht gibt, gerade in diesem sehr nahen Kontakt mit so jungen Mädels, junge Mädchen, Kinder. Es wird ja immer so von minderjährigen Frauen und so weiter. Das finde ich auch eine sehr interessante politische Einordnung, die da kommt. Aber diese ganze Idee des jungen Brunnens, dass das Silicon Valley dieses Longevity gerne in jeden Dimensionen austreiben möchte, dass die Google-Gründer, die ja auch eine Rolle spielen, zumindest einer davon, schon vor 15 Jahren mit der Idee kamen, wir machen einfach wie Flugzeugträger auf offenem Meer, damit wir nur dem internationalen Seerecht unterliegen, aber kein Land da eine Juristikation hat. Ja, wozu denn eigentlich und so? Also das finde ich alles wahnsinnig interessant, muss aber auch nicht auf spekulativer Art und Weise im Podcast ausdiskutiert werden. Also ich nehme sehr an, wir machen es jetzt einfach im Februar kurz, gehen wir mal durch, was so politisch gerade diskutiert wird. Ja, aber wie soll ich sagen?
Wir werden darauf denke ich immer wieder zu sprechen kommen, weil es dafür noch zu präsent ist und auch über die Fälle, die wir jetzt schon haben oder die da noch kommen mögen, hinausweist. Also weil es natürlich das auch ist, was wir jetzt ja über Jahre in Salon-Lektüren immer wieder erfahren haben, dass wir es mit einer Tech-Elite zu tun haben, die gerne für sich nochmal ganz eigene Regeln haben möchte oder gar keine Regeln und die setzt sie sich selbst. Wir haben es mit einer Tech-Elite zu tun, die den Menschen als zu defizitär ansieht, weshalb der optimiert werden muss. Und wir haben es mit einer Elite zu tun, die eigentlich die normalen Leute, also uns und alle, die zuhören, eigentlich als ein Menschenmaterial betrachtet, bei dem man nur mal gucken muss, wohin delegiert man die. Eine Zeit lang hat man es mit Cookies versucht, dass sie die richtigen Produkte kaufen, aber vielleicht kann man da auch nochmal weitergehen, als nur in ihnen Konsumenten sehen. Und das ist natürlich diese Dimension, die mich an der Geschichte auch interessiert. Du hast einen Clip mitgebracht.
Ja, wir hören einfach nur kurz Haio Schumacher. Genau, in der Hoffnung, dass einige kritisch, dass sie sich jetzt einfach wieder erkennen, in dieser Kritik von Haio Schumacher, weil ich glaube auch, er meinte mich.
Was mich wirklich erschüttert, ich habe mehrere Podcasts, deutsche Podcasts gehört, von Menschen, die ich für zurechnungsfähig hielt bis letzte Woche, die sich in einer Art über diese Files ausgelassen haben, ohne etwas zu wissen, ohne genaue Zusammenhänge zu kennen. Also ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass das irgendwas falsch oder richtig ist, aber im Moment sind wir noch in einem Stadium, wo diese ganzen vielen unterschiedlichen Dateien und Formate und groß und klein und Schnipsel und ich weiß nicht was alles, die sind noch gar nicht richtig systematisiert. Ich glaube, das hat System, aber ein anderes Ding. Aber einfach mal zu behaupten, es gibt tatsächlich die Pizza-Connection, von wegen Babys werden ausgesaugt, damit die Reichen länger leben. Also so eine klassische Verschwörungstheorie von wirklich bislang einigermaßen vernünftigen Menschen einfach so wiederholt. Pädophilievorwürfe, die wie ich finde, relativ hart sind. Das ist nach Psychologen-Meinung eine Krankheit. An der Charité in Berlin gibt es eine anonyme Hilfsnummer, weil ganz viele Menschen, die ein Problem damit haben, die vielleicht noch nicht straffällig geworden sind, aber merken, da ist etwas an ihnen, fühlen sich dermaßen stigmatisiert, dass sie überhaupt keine Traute haben, jetzt irgendwo hinzugehen und sich zu offenbaren. Da wird vorverurteilt. Ich war wirklich erschüttert, was das mit normalen Menschen macht. Der zweite Erschütterungspunkt, und ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst, aber diese Verschwörungserzählungen haben ja immer so eine gemeinsame Baseline und die heißt, es gibt ein Paralleluniversum, wo die Reichen und Mächtigen Dinge tun hinter unserem Rücken. Und wir sind ja nur die Dovys, die gesteuert werden. Und 9-Eleven war ein Fake und die Finanzkrise war ein Fake. Und natürlich war Covid auch ein Fake. Diese Verschwörungsbaseline wird natürlich durch Epstein und alles, was damit zusammenhängt, auf eine sehr merkwürdige Art bestätigt. Weil alle, die dachten, Bill Gates sei ein guter Mensch, ja, die denken sich, guck mal, da gibt es ja tatsächlich noch so eine zweite Ebene, so ein Paralleluniversum. Das ist das für mich wirklich giftige an dieser Epstein-Geschichte, dass alle Verschwörungstheoretiker hier ganz viel frisches Futter kriegen. Naja, also.
So, und dann diskutieren die auch ein bisschen drüber. Ich würde mal sagen, für den Fall, dass man sich hier wieder erkennt, jetzt wirklich keine Angst vor Verschwörungstheorien. Wir haben auch im Forum bei uns Leute gehabt, die dann schreiben, nee, Stefan ist ja auch immer sehr erpicht auf, das alles mit KI noch mal zu Fact checken. Ich habe Claude mal gefragt und dann Adenochrom eingegeben und dann kam sofort, nee, das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie. Und dann möchte ich sagen, ja, ja, genau. Die letzten zehn Jahre war so was eine Verschwörungstheorie. Die Pizza-Connection war eine Verschwörungstheorie. Nur wir wissen ja heute, und das ist nun wirklich relativ gesichert, dass Pizza, also das Wort, einfach wirklich Schiffrefahr für sexuelle Kontakte mit Menschen, mit denen da seriouristisch nicht auf sicheren Boden geht. Und dann hat man das halt umschrieben. Und man muss immer wieder darauf hinweisen, Donald Trump ist zum Beispiel gar keiner, der E-Mails schreibt. Also der taucht zwar 57.000 Mal oder was in diesen Pfeils auf, aber der hat nie eine E-Mail geschrieben. Es gibt auch noch eine Realität abseits von dem, was jetzt im Text belegt ist. Man kann ja von sich selber überlegen, was könnte man anhand der E-Mails aus dem eigenen Leben rekonstruieren? Und das ist halt sehr wenig. Also dass da noch viel ist und dass da noch viel Forensik gemacht werden muss, dass das auch journalistisch begleitet wird, aber wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch mal juristisch, auch wenn man da jetzt in der Amtszeit noch abwarten muss, wie auch immer. Also da würde ich sagen, jetzt nicht zu viel abräumen wie HJ. Schumacher, sondern da muss man jetzt neue Sensibilität aufbauen.
Ja, ja, aber ich glaube, man darf jetzt nicht anfangen zu raunen und sagen, ja, es ist da noch größer und da noch größer. Also das kann ich immer sagen. Und das ist ja auch etwas, was dann nicht überprüfbar ist. Wir können natürlich immer nur mit dem vorgehen, was wir haben. Und dann kann man aber von dem ausgehend ja eigentlich systemisch da was erkennen. Denn ich würde sagen, da wo die Verschwörungstheorie so funktioniert, dass, wie H. J. Schumacher das jetzt gerade beschreibt, wirklich so zwei Welten aufgemacht werden, dass man sagt, da gibt es so eine Welt im Untergrund oder eine Parallelwelt, in der regieren die Reichen und die können machen, was sie wollen dort. Und wir bekommen davon einfach gar nichts mit, außer wenn jetzt mal solche Enthüllungen kommen. Das ist natürlich so eine uralte Verschwörungstheorie, in der all die Machenschaften im Hintergrund laufen. Wo ich aber drauf Wert legen würde, ist, dass man anerkennt, es gibt ja sehr viele Verschwörungen. Und zwar dann nicht bei den von Hajo Schumachern genannten, aber wir haben ja lauter Verschwörungen gehabt. Also beispielsweise finde ich es auch bis heute skandalös, dass wir diesen NSU-Komplex haben und die hessische Landesregierung damals, ich glaube, es war die schwarz-grüne Landesregierung, hat entschieden, dass diese Akten jetzt jahrzehntelang unter Verschluss sind.
Jahrhunderte, 120 Jahre.
Ist in meinen Augen ein Indiz dafür, dass man das so unter Verschluss halten will. So sage ich es mal ganz offen, weil sonst würde man es ja nicht, ja, so, ne? Also es ist sehr logisch, Wolfgang, dieser Gedanke, ja. So und genau solche Punkte, über die muss viel mehr geredet werden. Wir hatten auch die Verschwörungstheorie wiederum, dass die Russen, die Pipeline gesprengt haben, stellte sich heraus, ne, waren gar nicht die Russen, war jemand anders. Auch das muss benannt werden. Das heißt, wenn wir über Verschwörungstheorien reden, wenn die so ein holistisches Bild uns bieten, ja, das ist ja, Verschwörungstheorien entstehen ja da, das ist ja auch ein Thema der Frankfurter Schule, vor allem da, wo man nicht sich mit dem Kapitalismus und seinen Widersprüchen und all dem auseinandersetzen will, sondern man versucht dann einfach so eine andere Erklärung zu finden und die führt dann eben zum Beispiel auch direkt in Antisemitismus oder sonst was. Aber was man schon erkennen muss, und darum geht es ja, dass mächtige Menschen Interesse haben und mächtige Menschen können diese Interessen oft viel besser durchsetzen. Warum? Weil sie Macht haben. Und wenn wir uns nun mal so was im Vergleich zu Epstein harmloses ansehen, wie die Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung, dann wissen wir aus der Lektüre von Sachbüchern, dass dahinter Zimmergespräche geführt werden, an einem öffentlichen Publikum weitgehend vorbei. Und dann werden dort mächtige Interessen mit Politikern direkt durchgesetzt. Dann kann man immer sagen, ja, aber das ist parlamentarisch dann abgefedert und so weiter und so fort. Aber trotzdem entstehen solche Verschwörungen. Deswegen würde ich auch ganz deutlich sagen, über Verschwörungen muss man reden. Denn wir wissen ja von einem liberalen Denker wie Lord Acton, Macht korrumpiert, absolute Macht korrumpiert, absolut. Deshalb muss man hier auch erkennen, es ist nicht so, es ist an allem einfach der Kapitalismus schuld. Denn wir können uns so ein Epstein-Fall auch in einer sozialistischen Gesellschaft vorstellen. Es geht darum, wer hat Macht und wer kann diese so sehr einsetzen, wie das hier geschehen ist. Und da sind wir eben noch gar nicht im Reich der Verschwörung und der Fälle, die wir nicht kennen, sondern wir wissen bereits jetzt, dass es dort Vergewaltigungen, Menschenhandel, all das gab. Und wie kann so etwas in einem solchen Umfang so lange mit so vielen namhaften Leuten betrieben werden, ohne dass es ans Licht kommt? Und da sprechen wir dann über eine Macht, die die Einfluss hat. Aber wir müssen auch erkennen, und das ist mir ganz wichtig zu sagen, dass es eben nicht nur Verschwörungen unter den Superreichen gibt. Denn wir hatten ja nun jetzt in den vergangenen Monaten den Fall Peliko. Im Fall Peliko haben wir es nicht mit Superreichen zu tun. Da haben wir es mit Normalbürgern zu tun. Da ist ein Mann, der seine Ehefrau über zehn Jahre lang betäubt und Männer in sein Haus lässt, die diese Frau dann vergewaltigen. Das wird gefilmt und so weiter. Das geht über zehn Jahre. Es sind über 50 Täter identifiziert. Wir wissen gar nicht, wie viel dann noch wäre in einem Umkreis von 100 Kilometern. Auch das ist die Realität, über die man dann genauso sprechen muss. Und bei dieser Elitenkritik, glaube ich, ist es schon ganz wichtig zu sagen, nein, wir haben momentan echt ein Problem mit einer Elite, die sich über die liberalen Institutionen stellt. Also es gibt eine Elitenkritik, die richtet sich sozusagen an den liberalen Institutionen aus. Also dass man zum Beispiel sagt, IWF ist problematisch. Wir sprechen ja im Salon über das Buch, weil dies und das. Und dann gibt es aber noch einmal eine Elitenkritik, die diese Eliten bespricht, die sagen, wir stehen sowieso außerhalb des Systems. Und das scheint ja bei einigen Leuten da bei Epstein der Fall zu sein. Weshalb ich auch sagen würde, weil manche dann gesagt haben, ja, aber man darf sich doch, weil Epstein ja dann aus dem Gefängnis rauskam, trotzdem mit dem Treffen, jeder hat doch eine zweite Chance verdient. Also im Sinne von, warum könnte ich denn das Leuten zum Vorwurf machen, dann würde ich sagen, ja, jeder mag eine zweite Chance verdient haben. Aber man wusste ja schon in diesen Kreisen doch von vielen Gerüchten mehr. Das wundert schon. Und die wundern mich vor allem, wenn irgendwelche Adelsdamen, die Vereine unterstützen für Opfer der sexuellen Gewalt, dann fünf Tage nach einer Haftentlassung eines Mannes, der wegen Menschenhandel angeklagt wurde, nichts Besseres zu tun haben, als mit dem Essen zu gehen. Da würde ich sagen, vielleicht könnte irgendjemand anders dem die zweite Chance gegeben haben, aber du hast einiges verloren. Es findet auch da zum Teil jetzt so eine Relativierung statt, die ich doch äußerst bedenklich finde.
Ja, absolut. Adam Tuss sagt zum einen, nicht ohne Grund Milliardäre verbieten. Du hast einen Grund, sie sind zu mächtig. Du kannst dich bei Sir Plus angucken, den Clip. In Amerika regeln die ein paar Sachen anders, wie zum Beispiel, du musst selber Bescheid sagen, in deinem nahen Umfeld, weshalb du verurteilt wurdest, wenn es um solche Fälle geht. Also man ist dann registriert. Man muss dann in der Nachbarschaft auch, man darf das nicht verstecken, was eben das Signal an die Nachbarschaft ist. Und wir wissen, wie das in Filmen ein bisschen übertrieben wird. Aber sensibel zu sein für solche Sachen, gerade weil es wie bei HL. Schumacher, selbst wenn die Leute es nicht wollten, niemanden schädigen wollten, ist halt Pädophilie eine Sache, die als Krankheit ausbricht und dann gibt es Opfer zu beklagen. Und dieser so semiöffentliche Umgang, dass man eigentlich in Amerika schon eine Resozialisierung möchte, deswegen kommen ja Leute aus dem Gefängnis wieder frei, aber sie sagen halt Bescheid und gehen relativ offen, erzwungenermaßen damit um. Und das hat anscheinend einfach nicht funktioniert. Also es ist niemand auf die Idee gekommen, die ganz, also sehr offensichtlichen Sachen dort einfach anzusprechen. Und das kennen wir ja immer wieder. Also das ist ja das typische Muster. Von daher hat dieser Pfeil halt so eine ganz innerweltliche Dramatik. Aber durch diesen Superreichtum, der da dazukommt, dass sich Leute einfach ganze Professuren als harem so halten, dass sie einfach Leute zusammenziehen, die Intelligenz da nochmal konsultieren, die auch nicht so genau wissen, warum stellt ihr mir jetzt diese Frage zu so und so. Also da kommt einfach ganz viel zusammen, was es halt so wahnsinnig interessant macht. Aber ich will nochmal sagen, wir haben jetzt auch Kommunalwahl in Hessen und in Bayern. Das betrifft Deutschland ganz doll. Also diese Erwartung, dass wir jetzt sozusagen stundenlang über den Epstein fallen. Ich hätte jetzt schon gar nicht mehr so viel zu sagen zum Monatsende. Also mal gucken, wie viel du da noch ausgräbst. Du hast ja jetzt intensiver nachgelesen.
Also mir geht es jetzt nicht darum, das alles abzuklappern, was da kommt. Dafür ist es auch einfach zu viel. Und zum Teil sind es ja auch Dinge, dass jetzt den seriösen Journalisten will ich das nicht unterstellen, sondern dass das ja so gerade in den Social Media oder in den Boulevard-Medien gerade so ist, dass jeder Name, der irgendwie in der Akte auftaucht, gleich eine Meldung wäre. Dass man sagt, die haben sich vielleicht in der E-Mail auch mal über XY unterhalten und deswegen steht dieser Name da drin. Aber dann steht man nicht in den Akten, in dem Sinne. Das ist ein bisschen albern gerade. Was mir noch mal wichtig ist, was ich so beobachten konnte, als ich mich jetzt so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt habe, war, dass es gerade in so rechten Milieus eine unglaubliche Freude an diesen Apps, die in Enthüllungen gibt und dass ich so dachte, ja, ihr badet so richtig in all dieser Grausamkeit, die wir bislang schon erfahren haben. Also wie mit diesen Mädchen umgegangen wurde und all das. Und dann dachte ich mir so, ah, es ist interessant. Warum ist da jetzt so ein hohes Interesse und so eine Freude an den Details und alles da? Und um immer wieder zu unterstreichen, wie pervers die da sind. Und die sind pervers. Das würde ich auch sagen, obwohl ich gleich sage, pervers ist eigentlich nicht der richtige Begriff dafür. Ja, also perversion, das haben wir. Aber wir wollen jetzt nicht Sexualtheorie und so weiter machen. Aber jedenfalls ist das also im höchsten Maße kriminell, was da geschieht. Jedenfalls habe ich dann zu Kenntnis genommen, dass es ja eine neue Studie gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du davon mitbekommen hast, die die Familienministerin vorgestellt hat. Die Lesubia, die Studie, diese Studie, also Lesubia meint Lebenssituation, Sicherheit und Belastung im Alltag. Das wurde mit 15.000 befragten Frauen und Männern repräsentativ, jetzt repräsentativ erhoben und ich dachte so, aha. Also möglicherweise ist auch diese obsessive Beschäftigung bei einigen mit Epstein so eine Externalisierung. Das Böse findet irgendwo da draußen statt und das ist natürlich auch typisch für Verschwörungstheorien. Das Böse findet irgendwo da draußen statt, bei den anderen, aber es findet nie bei uns statt. Und ich würde einfach gerne ein paar Clips noch spielen, um mal die Fälle zu beschreiben, die in unserer Wirklichkeit permanent stattfinden. Und die Zahlen sind wirklich erschreckend. Wir hören jetzt mal die Familienministerin Karin Prien.
Lassen Sie mich zu den zentralen Ergebnissen Ihnen ein paar Zahlen nennen. 16,1 Prozent, also jede sechste Person hat in ihrem Leben körperliche Gewalt durch den aktuellen oder ehemaligen Partner oder die Partnerin erfahren. Psychische Gewalt in einer Partnerschaft erleben oder erlebten 44,5 Prozent der Frauen und Männer mindestens einmal in ihrem Leben, also nahezu jeder zweite. Auch sexuelle Belästigung hat fast jede zweite Person in ihrem Leben erfahren. 17,8 Prozent der Frauen, also mehr als jede sechste Frau, hat in ihrem Leben einen sexuellen Übergriff erlebt.
Ja, das sind erschütternde Zahlen, wie ich finde. Wir hören mal weiter, was sie sagt.
Frauen sind insgesamt häufiger und schwerer von Gewalt betroffen als Männer und sie sind häufig mehrfach Opfer geworden. Sie haben größere Angst, tragen mehr Verletzungen davon und haben auch mit Blick auf Lebensgefahr eine höhere Einschätzung. Bei Partnerschaftsgewalt liegt die Anzeigekvote deutlich unter 5 Prozent. Das macht deutlich, das Dunkelfeld ist riesig.
Sieht das jetzt noch mal aus. Diese Dunkelziffer ist erschreckend und ich will ganz kurz noch anmerken, das wurde ja in allen seriösen Medien sehr groß gespielt, die Veröffentlichung dieser Studie. Aber wenn man sich zum Beispiel ansieht, wer hat sich die Pressekonferenz bei YouTube angesehen, die bei Phoenix übertragen wurde, dann kommt man da auf knapp 5000 Klicks. Das heißt, was ich so ein bisschen tragisch finde ist, dass man jetzt gerade sich sehr darin suhlt, bei jedem Adligen und jedem Promi 50.000 Artikel zu lesen. Was war da mit Epstein? Und dass man aber genau das, was hier an Gewalt in unserer Gesellschaft stattfindet, an Missbrauch in unserer Gesellschaft stattfindet, so sehr übergeht. Das hat ein bisschen was, was wir immer wieder erleben können. Das wurde ein bisschen Star und Sein und Rummel und alles dazugehört. Dann ist das plötzlich interessanter. Aber in gewisser Weise für uns alle hier ist das relevanter. Wir hören uns das nochmal an zu den Dunkelziffern.
Zur Anzeigebereitschaft lässt sich das Folgende sagen. Sehr viele Frauen und Männer erleben partnerschaftliche Gewalt, ohne dass sie sie jemals zur Anzeige bringen. Bei Partnerschaftsgewalt liegt die reale Anzeigekote deutlich unter 5 Prozent. Das macht deutlich, wie groß das Dunkelfeld ist. Mehr als 19 von 20 Taten werden nicht angezeigt.
Ja, also das haben wir auch als ernsthaftes Phänomen im öffentlichen Raum, dass Eltern zum Beispiel aus Ungeduld und Alltagseile und so gewaltsam ihren eigenen Kindern gegenüber sind. Und die meisten Leute nicht wissen, dass das eigentlich ein Fall für die Polizei ist. Also dass man in dem Moment selber die Polizei ruft und sagt, hier gibt es Vorfälle, weil die klären das untereinander wie auch immer. Und dann werden irgendwie Kinder an den Armen durch die Straßen geschleift und lauter solche Sachen. Ja, das beginnt bei, man ist völlig unbeteiligt und ruft zu wenig die Polizei oder sowas.
Wir hören nochmal Karin Prien.
Besonders erschütternd ist der Blick auf die Kindheit. Jede zweite Person berichtet von körperlicher Gewalt durch Eltern oder Erziehungsberechtigte jeder Vierte von Gewalt zwischen den Eltern.
Also für körperliche Gewalt und sexuellen Missbrauch ist die Familie die Einflugsschneise. Das wissen typischerweise auch alle professionell Darangedockten. Also wenn man, es gibt dieses sehr, ich hätte jetzt fast pervers gesagt, aber es ist ein ganz krusiges Phänomen, nämlich das Münchhausen bei Proxy.
Kennst du das?
Nein.
Frauen und Männer brauchen Aufmerksamkeit. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen psychologisch das gut erarbeitet, aber ich bin ja auch kein Psychologe. Und verletzen dann ihr Kind, um einen Arzt rufen zu können, der dann seinerseits sorgenvoll und mitleidig auch mit den Eltern umgeht. Deshalb solche Rettungskräfte angehalten sind, wenn ein Kind verletzt ist, sich nicht zu sehr um die Eltern zu kümmern. Also nicht diese fehlerhafte Sorgfalt den Eltern gegenüber, diese Aufmerksamkeit den Eltern gegenüberzugen, sondern sagen, nein, wir kümmern uns hier nur um das Kind, was auch dazu führt, dass sich Eltern manchmal sehr ungerecht behandelt fühlen von solchen Rettungskräften, wenn nämlich der Rettungsdienst kommt und sie als Eltern werden behandelt wie jeder andere. Also wo einfach diese Nähe nicht mehr hergestellt wird. Also es ist ein extrem schwieriger Umgang. Und der kommt aus dieser Erfahrung heraus, dass Eltern krasse Fehlverhalte zeigen können. Also wie wir es uns nicht vorstellen können. Aber halt inzwischen gut dokumentiert. Und dieses Münchhausen bei Proxy, als ich das da das erste Mal gehört habe, hab ich auch gedacht, das kann alles gar nicht sein. Also es wäre sozusagen, da gehen sofort die Alarmglocken an. Ja, man würde sofort, aber nein, das sind alles reale Phänomene, die es wirklich in sich haben.
Ja, ich sprach mal mit einem Psychiater, der für sehr harte Fälle da zuständig war, was Missbrauch und all das anbelangt. Und der sagte, ja, es gibt auch in der Öffentlichkeit so eine große Externalisierung eben raus, aus der Familie, aus dem Freundeskreis. Und dann mag man es eigentlich, sich auf diese Skandale zu kaprizieren, um ja, in gewisser Weise auch zu verdrängen, was eigentlich stattfindet, noch stattfindet. Ich bin ganz überrascht gewesen über die Zahl, die Alexander Dobrindt, also der Innenminister, hier noch fallen lässt.
Wenn man in die Studie schaut, dann stellt man fest, dass fast jeder Zwanzigste betroffen ist von der Anwendung von K.o.-Tropfen. Und wir sehen, dass das besonders eine ganz junge Bevölkerungsgruppe betrifft.
Ja, und da musste ich natürlich gleich an Epstein und die Gerüchte und die Tatsachen und all das Denken, also wie Menschen das Bewusste gestohlen wird, das Bewusstsein ausgenockt wird, um dann alles mit ihnen machen zu können. Also ich bin ja sehr schockiert über diese Zahlen, die jetzt so in dieser Form wohl zum ersten Mal vorliegen. Man kann sich mal diese ganze Pressekonferenz ansehen, eine Stunde Phoenix, das lohnt sich dann. Und ja, damit würde ich sagen, schließen wir unseren kleinen Zwischenruf zur Klarstellung ab und würden dann vielleicht jetzt noch so 15 Minuten aus dem Salon spielen. Wir haben ja über das Buch von Patrick Kaczmarczyk gesprochen, das uns beiden sehr gut gefallen hat. Und hier gibt es jetzt für alle die ersten 15 Minuten.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Trump's Way or the Highway? Stimmst du zu?
Möglicherweise schon.
Ja, das ist nämlich ganz erstaunlich. Wir haben ja also ein Buch mit einem Vorwort, das es in sich hat von Heiner Flassbeck. Und es sind Sachen, die wir schon wissen, aber sie nochmal offensichtlich auf so kurzen, also so offensichtlich dargeboten auf so kurzen Raum, ja, einfach als der große Hinweis, man braucht für die Politik der Welt und damit ist auch jeder einzelne Wähler gemeint, der sich daran gliedert, ein intellektuelles Fundament oder ein Überbau oder wie man das auch immer bezeichnen. Und wenn man sich das so anschaut, haben wir ja schon häufiger das Plädoyer dafür gemacht, zu sagen, man kann die Kohle auch einfach raushauen. Ja, man muss jetzt nicht jedes Mal eine Verteilungsdebatte im Sinne von der Bundeshaushalt ist nur so und so groß. Wenn wir jemanden was geben, müssen wir jemanden was wegnehmen. Also wie viel weniger bei den Bürgergeldempfänger sollen es denn sein, damit wir uns Deutschlandige leisten können oder was auch immer. Und jetzt sagt Heiner Flassberg einfach völlig verkehrte Frage und offensichtlich ist auch der Einzige auf der Welt, der das versteht, Donald Trump, der nämlich Amerika regiert und Amerika hat es schon immer so gemacht. Was kostet die Welt? Ach so, ja dann Billionen.
Er schreibt, während die gesamte Welt und selbst Europa vom IWF gemahnt und gedrängt werden, in Sachen Staatsschulden die Kirche im Dorf zu lassen, erlauben sich diverse Regierungen der USA eine Schuldenexplosion, die ihresgleichen sucht. Wüsste man, dass die amerikanische Position unhaltbar und auf Dauer wirtschaftlich schädlich ist, man könnte sich beruhigt zurücklehnen und auf den Tag warten, an dem die amerikanische Illusion an der Wirklichkeit zerschellt. Doch was, wenn es umgekehrt ist, wenn der amerikanische Pragmatismus in Sachen Staatsverschuldung vollkommen gerechtfertigt und notwendig wäre, um in dieser Welt erfolgreich zu wirtschaften.
Ja, das ist doch, und er sagt es dazu, niemand kann darauf eine exannte Antwort geben. Aber die Frage ist so trifftig, dass wir uns als diejenigen, die nun wirklich auch selbst über ihr Geld bestimmen, wir hängen ja nicht vom Dollar ab, wir haben ja ein Euro, wir haben beim Zahlungsverkehr ein bisschen ab, aber das ist ja Service. Äh, also wir stehen hier vor, wie soll man sagen, wir wollen ja Trump eigentlich abklären und so, aber jetzt holt er sich einen neuen Fatshelf, der ihm natürlich die, und den Joke hab ich ja immer gemacht, wenn jemand Geld braucht, ich fahr doch immer bei der EZB vorbei, ich kann auch den Brief dort reintun, in den Briefkasten bei denen und sagen, bitte überweisst, und die machen das ja auch. Die schreiben ja selber flehende Briefe, bitte gib die Kohle aus. Und das, ja, jetzt wird Trump noch mal drei Jahre mit einem eigenen Fatshelf regieren und das genauso machen. Der einzig vernünftige Weg und der einzige, der's macht.
Wir lesen das Buch Zerfall der Weltordnung Die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens von Patrick Kaczmarczyk. Patrick Kaczmarczyk ist Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und er kennt sich aus in internationalen Beziehungen. Er war jetzt auch stellvertretendes Mitglied der Expertenkommission der Bundesregierung zur Reform der Schuldenbremse. Und er ist jemand, der ja internationale Entwicklungsarbeit wirklich kennt, denn er war dort tätig. Er kennt sich außerdem sehr gut aus, was Ostafrika belangt, wie auch den Nahen Osten. Er hat ja auch mit Adam Toos in der Zeit einen Artikel zum Krieg in Gaza veröffentlicht. Patrick Kaczmarczyk schafft es also wirklich einen globalen Blick auf die Welt einzunehmen. Wir lesen also jetzt zum zweiten Mal dicht hintereinander ein Buch, nachdem wir Branko Milanovic schon gelesen haben, das sich ja traut, einmal aus so einer rein eurozentrischen oder westlichen Perspektive auszubrechen. Aber nicht in dem Sinne so, ich guck da jetzt mal so mit einer romantisierten Art oder so drauf, sondern hier ist jemand, der weiß, wie die Institutionen funktionieren, der weiß, was Schulden da und dort bedeuten, wie Geldpolitik in den USA sich auswirkt auf die gesamte Welt. Und er ist jemand, der versteht, in Bilanzen zu denken. Weshalb auch interessant ist, dass er immer wieder uns zeigt, wenn wir hier den einen oder anderen Schritt fordern, also mit wir meine ich jetzt die westliche Hemisphäre, mit ihren Institutionen, dann hat das drastische Auswirkungen, es sind skandalöse Zahlen, das Buch ist voller skandalöser Zahlen, was ich vor allem bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass er immer wieder auf China zu sprechen kommt und damit ja auch schon diese Verbindung zu dem Fluffspeck vor Wort hergestellt ist, denn was wir hier sehen, ist ja, dass Trump sich nicht um irgendwelche EBF-Maßgaben schert und überhaupt die USA da immer wieder von sich gelöst hat und gesagt hat, wir machen hier unser eigenes Ding, wir investieren auch groß da, wo es sein muss, wir merken das jetzt gerade auch bei dem KI-Hype und dieses Buch beschäftigt sich ja auch mit dem Aufstieg Chinas und zeigt ja, China hat sich dem internationalen Währungsfonds und der Weltbank auch nicht in dem Maße unterworfen, wie das andere Entwicklungsländer getan haben oder tun mussten vor allem. Und das bedeutet, dass also wo man sich gerade der marktliberalen Logik entziehen kann, dass dort tatsächlich der Aufstieg geschieht, während diejenigen, die an diese Logik gebunden sind und noch nicht mächtig sind, also es ist immer eine Politik der Mächtigen gegen die, die noch ohnmächtig sind, dass man dann auch auf einem niedrigen Entwicklungsstatus bleiben wird. Es sind sehr, sehr wichtige Erkenntnisse, die wir hier rausziehen können und alles Themen, die kaum präsent sind in unserem Diskurs über globale Gerechtigkeit und all das.
Das ist ja in Deutschland, also da hat er ja einige Pointen, auf die wir gleich zu sprechen kommen. Das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, für Amerika, gilt ja für Deutschland. Aber wir werden gleich nochmal auffächern, ob es jetzt für die deutsche Bevölkerung von Bedeutung ist. Aber insgesamt haben wir ja schon diese Beobachtung gemacht die letzten Jahre, dass wenn eine Krise droht, der IWF dann immer kommt und sagt, Beispiel Griechenland, die Troika, also IWF, Europäische Kommission, Europäische Zentralbank, ihr müsst sparen, ihr dürft nichts mehr ausgeben, ihr dürft nur noch einnehmen, bitte verkauft alles. Während in Deutschland Krise, Abfragprämie, wir geben euch Geld, kauft ein Auto. Krise, Lohnfortzahlung bei Auftragsflaute. Diese Nullrunden, nicht Nullrunden, sondern diese, wie heißt es?
Kurzarbeitergeld.
Kurzarbeitergeld, genau. Betriebe werden stillgelegt wegen Corona. Sie werden Corona-Hilfen gezahlt, dass es danach Skandal mit diesen Rückzahlungen gibt und so mal eingepasst. Aber wir haben auch nie so auf eine Krise reagiert, dass wir gesagt haben, ah Krise, wir machen erst mal alle Krankenhäuser zu. Wie der IWF einfacher sagt, Gesundheitsausgaben. Das finde ich interessant, dass dann der Wirtschaftsrat kommt, der CDU. Also dass der IWF die brutale Politik für den globalen Süden jetzt als innenpolitische Maßnahme zu Hause vorschlägt, als in Form von CDU-Politik. Das sind natürlich so tagesaktuelle politische Pointen, will man mal sagen, die wirklich schlimm sind, wenn man so ein Buch gerade liest. Also Einführung, Krankheitsbild. Wir kriegen eine richtige Diagnose. Die Weltordnung zerfällt. Ich war mir ein bisschen unklar im Verlauf des Textes, ob hier wirklich eine Weltordnung zerfällt, oder in den letzten Zügen der nochmal Einbetonierung gerade steckt. Also es ist weniger mit einem Zerfall als, es könnte sein, dass es demnächst einfach in die Luft fliegt, so. Weil bei Milanovic haben wir ja schon so die langsamen, also er hätte ja auch beschrieben, bei dem Entwicklungsgrade jetzt gerade wird Amerika noch über Jahrzehnte dominant bleiben. Der Dollar unausweichlich und so, ne?
Ja, vielleicht hat Kaczmarczyk aber da Recht, wenn er von einem Zerfall der Weltordnung spricht. Denn es ist natürlich etwas, was sehr schrittweise funktioniert und auch nur schrittweise funktionieren kann, es sei denn, es wäre da eine andere Ordnung dann da. Also wenn wir jetzt über das Ende dieser Weltordnung reden oder vom Zerfall dieser Weltordnung, dann schwingt er ja immer so mit und dann kommt die neue Ordnung. Also beispielsweise China als ordnende Macht. Aber das ist ja auch nicht zu sehen. Also wir sehen ein mächtiges China und auch wie China mächtiger wird. Genau, aber wir werden nicht sehen, dass das jetzt wie nach 45 die neue Weltordnung wird. Deshalb ist vielleicht Zerfall ganz gut. Man muss auch dann sagen, aber auch ein genereller Zerfall der Weltordnung. Man könnte vielleicht behaupten, dass es dann eine dauerhafte Weltunordnung ist, in der wir leben. Jedenfalls ist dieser Gedanke, auf die eine Ordnung kommt die nächste Ordnung, nicht so sinnvoll zu denken. Und wir haben es eher mit so einem Zerfall zu tun, was aber ja sehr viele Akteure, die noch an dieser alten Weltordnung festhalten und sie aufrechterhalten wollen, zu Maßnahmen führt, dass sie jetzt so eine Überreaktion gerne am liebsten, oder man könnte es vielleicht eher sagen, so eine Angstblüte erleben wir bei denen, dass sie jetzt nochmal gerade besonders vehement eine Weltordnung verteidigen wollen, was dann natürlich auch ziemlich viele Konflikte mit sich bringen kann.
Oder es ist eben was wir in Davos auch beobachtet haben, oder schon in diesem Vinnozieler Fall. Und das liegt eben dieses Vorwort nahe in dem Flasberg-Aufteil zwischen der materiellen und der ideellen Weltordnung. Was wir auf jeden Fall sehen, ist ein Fall der ideellen Weltordnung. Also dass Trump sich nicht mehr die Mühe macht, sein Militärs zu erklären, wir fahren jetzt nach Venezuela wegen den Frieden und der Freiheit, sondern wir machen das nur wegen dem Öl, zeigt ja, dass die materielle Weltordnung schlägt jetzt auf die intellektuelle Weltordnung durch, statt da noch ein gegen oder ein erweitertes Programm zu fahren. Und das muss man ja auch erstmal aushalten. Das gab es ja nicht ohne Grund. Ja. Sagen wir mal so. Und so ist ja auch der Einstieg ins Buch. Also Flasberg redet noch von der 200 Jahre alten englischen Theorie des internationalen Handels, die, würde ich jetzt sagen, einfach so, was man so intuitiv halt denkt, formuliert. Und Patrick beginnt damit der Belle Epoque, also der schönen Epoche zwischen den Kriegen 1871 bis 1914, die Hochphase des damaligen Internationalismus. Man hatte sich gerade so eingerichtet, bis dann die Katastrophe des ersten Weltkriegs, noch keine neue stabile Nachkriegsordnung, hergestellt hat, weil sei ja Vertrag, es hat ja dann das wieder gedauert. Und so könnte man ja auch diesem intellektuellen Teil, diesem Überbau nachgehen und sagen, naja, in dieser schönen Zeit bis 1914 gab es Ideen der internationalen Zusammenarbeit, die wurden dann im ersten Weltkrieg zertrümmert. Die materielle Unordnung wurde nicht durch neue Ideen wieder aufgefangen, sondern man war einfach wütend, man hatten einen wütenden Überbau. Wir zerren euch jetzt aus, wir bauen euch den Ruhrpott ab und so weiter. Und das führt dann natürlich dann in die größere Katastrophe, was ja bedeutet, ein Zerfall der ideellen Weltordnung, dem sollte man ganz ernst nehmen. Also wenn wir, also das ist sozusagen der Unterschied zwischen Katastrophe, erster und zweiter Weltkrieg, 100 Millionen Tote mehr, einfach nur, weil eine ideelle Weltordnung zerfiel oder gar nicht erst etabliert wurde zu materiellen Durcheinander.
Und dann kommt das, was man gerne als regelbasierte Ordnung beschrieben hat, also nach 45, wobei gleich eine paradoxe Situation ausgemacht wird. Da heißt es, wir sehen uns einerseits als Verfechter des freien Marktes, haben andererseits aber keine Probleme, unsere Wirtschaft durch Protektionismus und Interventionen zu schützen. Einerseits werfen wir anderen Ländern vor, mit Exportüberschüssen gegen die Regeln des Freihandels zu verstoßen. Andererseits sind wir stolz auf unsere eigenen Überschüsse, die alles übersteigen, was man in den größten Volkswirtschaften dieser Welt finden kann. Und dann zählt ja noch weitere Widersprüche auf, dass also diese Wirtschaftsordnung, die dann etabliert wird und die durch die westlichen Institutionen aufrechterhalten wird, eigentlich ein Widerspruch nach dem anderen produziert wird, von dem die Länder des globalen Südens, oder sagen wir alle Länder, die nicht der Westen sind, wissen. Das heißt, wenn wir uns jetzt gerade wundern, warum es so einen starken Vertrauensentzug des globalen Südens gibt, dann hängt das mit vielen Dingen zusammen, zumindest hängt es auch damit zusammen, dass es alternative Angebote gibt in der multipolaren Weltordnung. Und diese Entwicklungsländer zum ersten Mal auch Möglichkeiten haben, sich für den einen oder anderen oder sogar beide Partner gleichzeitig zu entscheiden, während sie vorher doch sehr an der Kandare geführt wurden und mussten sich eigentlich immer nur diesem westlichen Regime unterwerfen. Wenn man auch hinzufügen muss, das ist noch sehr, sehr stark. Also wir haben es jetzt noch nicht mit einer Welt zu tun, in der man sagen kann, IWF und Weltbank verlieren an Macht. Aber wir sehen neu aufkommende Akteure.
Ich habe mich auch an diesem Einstieg ein bisschen festgebissen. Da ist doch mehr drin, als jetzt der Text selbst bot. Denn Woodrow Wilson war in Amerika von 1913 bis 21 Präsident. Führte dann Amerika auch in den Ersten Weltkrieg und hatte aber schon eine Nachkriegsordnung, Stichwort Völkerbund, im Hinterkopf. Heute wissen wir, die Idee war ungefähr so gut wie die der UN. Wie gut die UN war, sehen wir. Also 80 Jahre Frieden und jetzt so ein bisschen durcheinander. Und die Ironie der Geschichte ist auch, dass man damals den Vertrag von Versailles und so weiter gemacht hat, weil die gute Idee des amerikanischen Präsidenten, der also Truppen in den europäischen Krieg, erster Weltkrieg geführt hat, vom eigenen Kongress nicht unterstützt wurde. Das hieß, am Ende gab es einen Völkerbund, aber der amerikanische Kongress hat seinem eigenen Präsidenten die Unterschluss verwehrt, da teilzunehmen. Was bedeutet, die erste Idee, eine UN zu gründen, ging nicht auf, weil der Ideengeber und größter, damals auch schon bedeutendster Anteilgeber, nicht Teil war. Das sind also alles solche kleinen Stolpersteine in der Geschichte, wo man sich fragen könnte, was lernen wir denn daraus? So insgesamt. Wenn sich jetzt Amerika wieder aus allem rauszieht und man sich fragt, ja, Herr Karne, gut gebrüllt, Löwe, aber willst du jetzt eine Mittelmächte-Idee aufbauen ohne Amerika, die aber noch mal dafür da ist, den globalen Süden weiter zu ignorieren? Denn das ist noch mal ein wichtiger Hinweis, auch in vielen Kommentaren, die wir bekommen hatten. Nein, Karne hat auf den globalen Süden keine Rücksicht genommen. Nein, nein, nein. Der Stub aus Finnland hat das ganz kurz angemerkt in einem Gespräch zu seinem Buch in Davos. Hat keiner hingeschaut. Aber der Karne hat auf den globalen Süden keine Rücksicht genommen. Sondern es ging um die Idee, die Mittelmächte noch mal ohne Amerika zu ertüchtigen, das Programm weiterzufahren. Schwierig.
Ja, ja. Also ich will das auch noch mal deutlich machen, weil das mir auch aufgefallen ist, als würde hier so getan, weil die Rhetorik ja so ist. Du hattest ja zu Recht gesagt, es klingt so ein bisschen, als hätte die Afrikanische Union sich entschlossen, mal so eine antikolonialistische Rede zu formulieren. Nein.
Das war Patrick. Just heute, wo wir das hier spielen, ist er in der Stadt. Ich zeige ihm unsere Bar.
Sehr gut. Wer jetzt noch unsere weitere Diskussion hören möchte, zwei Stunden haben wir über das neue Buch von Patrick diskutiert und dann noch unsere Empfehlungen vorgestellt, Bücher, Texte, Musik, was man so erlebt haben könnte, sollte in diesem Monat. Das kann man alles hören, wenn man uns abonniert, den Salon abonniert, das ist möglich über Patreon, Apple und Steady. Die Links stehen alle in der Beschreibung oder einfach auf die Seite www.neuezwanziger.de gehen. Bis dann.
Bis dann.